The central limit theorem is
absolutely remarkable.
It is a very deep result,
and highly
nontrivial and non intuitive.
There's no apparent reason why
this random variable here, a
standardized version of the
sum of random variables,
should have an approximately
normal distribution.
Furthermore, it is very useful,
and one key reason is
that it is universal.
It doesn't matter what the
distribution of the X's is.
No matter what the distribution
is, still in the
limit, this standardized version
of the sum is going to
behave like a normal
random variable.
And if we wish to apply it to
particular examples or models,
the only thing that we need to
know about the distribution of
the X's are the corresponding
means and variances, as we're
going to see in multiple
examples.
When we apply it, it turns out
to be very accurate, and it is
also a very nice computational
shortcut.
Even if we knew, in detail, the
distribution of the X's,
in order to calculate the
distribution of Sn, we would
have to take the distribution
of the X's and convolve it
with itself n times, something
that can be
computationally tedious.
Whereas the computations that
are involved, when we use the
central limit theorem, are
very, very simple, as the
examples that will be coming
up will show to us.
Finally, at the philosophical
level, the central limit
theorem justifies why models
involving normal random
variables are very natural.
Whenever you have a phenomenon
or an object that's affected
by multiple noise sources, and
if these noise sources are
independent, then the overall
effect of those noise sources
is going to be well-modeled by a
normal random variable, even
if the distribution of each one
of these noise sources is
very different from
being normal.
And this is a reason why, in
many, many applications in
many different fields, normal
random variables provide very
useful and accurate models.
Since the central limit theorem
is so useful and
important, it is worth making
sure that we understand
exactly what it says and to
make a few comments on its
mathematical content.
What it says is the following.
We take the sum of independent
identically distributed random
variables, we form this
standardized version of the
sum, where we subtracted the
mean and divide by the
standard deviation of the sum,
and then what it tells us is
that the CDF of this random
variable, Zn, converges to the
normal CDF.
So what we have is a statement
about CDFs.
It does not yet tell us
anything specific
about PDFs or PMFs.
So for example, if Sn and the
X's are all continuous random
variable, so Zn is also
continuous, you might wonder
whether the PDF of Zn converges
to a normal PDF.
It turns out that there are
results of this kind that
assert convergence of the PDF,
or even PMF, of this random
variable to a normal
PDF, in some sense.
But these results generally need
a few more mathematical
assumptions for the results
to be valid.
Nevertheless, when we show
pictures of various examples,
we will do this by showing
pictures of PDFs and PMFs
because these are easier
to visualize.
Now since the result is so
general and so important, it
might be worth understanding
to what extent it can be
generalized to other contexts.
Our main two assumptions are
that the random variables are
independent and identically
distributed.
Can we remove those
assumptions?
There are versions of the
central limit theorem that
apply to the case where the
Xi's are not identically
distributed.
One just needs to make certain
assumptions on the means and
to the variances of the Xi's.
Some conditions will
be needed.
Also, the assumption of
independence does not need to
be literally true.
There are versions of the
central limit theorem that are
valid when we have just
weak dependence.
That is, nearby X's may be
dependent, but if you compare
X5 with X of 1 million, then
these two random variables are
essentially independent.
In those cases, we can still
apply a suitable version of
the central limit theorem.
And finally, you may
be curious how
this result is proved.
One way of proving it, which is
the way it was originally
established a long time ago,
for the special case of
Bernoulli random variables X,
in which case S is binomial.
The way it was established was
by carrying out algebraic
manipulations on the
binomial formulas.
But this was a derivation that
would not generalize.
For the general case, the
proof is obtained using
so-called transform methods,
which is a topic that we're
not covering, but it
goes as follows.
We consider this function of the
random variable Zn, where
s is some parameter, and we
show that this expectation
converges to the corresponding
expectation if you have the
standard normal Z in
the place of Zn.
And this is true for all s, or
at least for all s in some
rich enough set.
And then, one appeals to some
deep mathematical results that
tell you that if this kind of
expectation converges to that
expectation, then the CDF of Zn
must also converge to the
CDF of Z. But this is a proof
that involves various steps
and appeals to some deep results
from other fields of
mathematics.
And finally, there is
the practical side.
What exactly does it say
and how do we use it?
Since the CDF of Zn can be
approximated by the CDF of a
standard normal, this means that
in practice, we can treat
the random variable Zn just as
if it were a standard normal.
But now, we notice that
Sn is obtained as a
linear function of Zn.
Namely, the definition of Zn
gives us this formula.
So, Sn is a linear
function of Zn.
If we pretend that Zn is normal,
and since linear
functions of normal random
variables are normal, this
means that we will also pretend
that Sn is normal.
So in practice, the way to
carry out calculations is
often to just pretend that Sn is
normal with the appropriate
mean and variance.
These are the correct means and
variance of Sn, and that's
the only information that we
need in order to apply it.
If we know mu and sigma squared,
and using the normal
approximation, then we have an
approximate distribution for
Sn, and we can go ahead.
Now in practice, can we use the
central limit theorem when
n is moderate?
For example, if n is 30,
can you apply the
central limit theorem?
This is a relation that's true
in the limit of very large n.
How large should n be?
It turns out that the central
limit theorem gives us very
good approximations even when n
has moderately small values.
Now, these approximations
sometimes will be better and
sometimes worse.
It helps if the distribution
of the X's that you're
starting with has some common
one features with the normal
distribution.
If the X's are already normal,
then S will be normal and
there's no approximation
involved.
If the X's are close to normal,
then for fairly small
values of n, S will be very
well modeled by a normal
random variable.
Now, what does it mean that the
distribution of the X's
looks a little bit like
the normal one?
It helps if the distribution is
symmetric around its mean,
and it also helps if it is
unimodal, in the sense that it
has a single peak rather
than multiple peaks.